this week brought very conflicting
signals on the state of the u.s economy
on friday the government's employment
report for the month of april saw a
better than expected gain of almost 430
000 jobs with unemployment remaining at
3.6 percent but friday also closed out a
volatile week on wall street three major
indices lost ground for the week for the
s p 500 it was the fifth losing week in
a row the longest streak in more than a
decade joining us to talk all about it
is cbs news senior business analyst jill
schlesinger jill good morning and what
can you tell us about this jobs report
you know this was a solid report as you
said slightly better than expected on
job creation rate stays near those
50-year lows just above and about but
overall in the last year we have
actually seen 6.6 million jobs created
in the u.s economy it's a very strong
number and if you think about it this is
amazing because we had lost 22 million
in the spring of 2020 and now we've
recovered 95
of those jobs so that's really good on
the wage front we saw wages up by five
and a half percent sounds good but as we
know that leaves a lot of americans
short with inflation running at about
eight and a half percent annually
jill it was a wild week uh for the
markets um some big swings which it
panicked i think a lot of people where
do you think the markets are right now
and what should investors be thinking
you know i think everyone is really
focused on the federal reserve we had a
federal reserve meeting this week they
raised interest rates by a half of a
percentage point that was the biggest
increase in more than 20 years and it
looks like what the fed is really trying
to do is delicately balance the u.s
economy they don't want to raise rates
by so much that we actually end up
slowing down and going into a recession
but they've got to keep raising rates
because inflation remains so high so
think of it this way they're driving a
car it's speeding down the highway and
right now if they slam the brakes on we
end up in a recession ditch if they just
tap the brakes too lightly we keep
speeding along and that is a tough job
for the fed
jill you know people have retirement
accounts they're concerned about you say
this to us every week on the call if
your money's there you don't need it
just keep it there
if you need to retire it's a little more
worrisome what about even just savers
and
borrowers right now what do they need to
worry about well
so let's look at three different
categories if you're an investor and
you're long term you're right you've got
to kind of keep on keeping on that's
what you do if you are a saver and
interest rates are rising here's
something really good you could start
seeing higher interest rates credited in
your savings and checking and money
market accounts now those go very slowly
on the way up right and that's very
difficult if you're a saver if you're a
borrower of course you're going to see
higher rates on credit cards on auto
loans on those adjustable rate mortgages
some small business loans and i think
that the the struggle here as a consumer
is that you're trying to figure out what
do i do with my money and i think the
reality is if you're a borrower things
cost more if you're a saver you're
earning a little bit of interest but not
enough to keep pace with inflation one
interesting idea to consider for people
who are really freaked out about
inflation and have some money the
government has
inflation-linked savings bonds they're
called i-bonds and those bonds right now
are using a
two parts of of the bond and you get a
total interest rate of
9.62 percent between now and october
you've got to hold those bonds from one
to five years it's only ten thousand
dollars maximum that you can put in for
each calendar year but if you're worried
that's not a terrible place to park some
money
very interesting idea jill thank you
very much as always